- Hey everybody, my name
is Santiago Giraldo.
I am the Senior Director
of Product Marketing
for Artificial Intelligence at Snowflake.
I'm joined here today with Brian Neumann,
who is the SVP of Engineering for Decile,
one of our customers that's using
our latest innovation called
Snowflake Intelligence.
So to dive right in, we
recently made an announcement
around the release of
Snowflake Intelligence
to address a very critical problem
that many enterprises face today.
And that's the disparities
and the differences
between how business teams and
data teams actually operate
and work together to solve problems.
Up until today, and really
I'm sure a lot of you
have experienced, that there's a big gap
between how the business
users actually utilize data
and how the data teams
actually deliver that data.
One of the big disparities that we've seen
is the fact that data
teams spend a lot of cycles
creating static reports or
reports that take a lot of time
to actually reach that insight.
And by the time that you
actually get that insight,
it's already too late to act.
The solutions that we have
today tend to be very rigid
and face a lot of problems
in terms of how you actually
answer and solve problems.
So as an example, today
it's very easy to ask, what?
It's very easy to ask,
what did my sales look like last week?
What campaigns, how did they perform?
But one of the big critical gaps here
is that those are very singular questions
that don't get at the
real crux of the problem,
which is answering the why things happen
and being able to critically
analyze and understand
what to do next.
It's hard for business
teams and data teams
to be on the same page.
You have fragmented data
in very disparate systems
across different databases.
You have siloed insights that oftentimes
are coming too late
for you to actually act
and to make decisions.
And by the time you actually get that data
and you're able to make those decisions
and understand what's happening,
it's already a bit too late.
So what if we changed that?
What if we made it
possible for every employee
across your organization to simply be able
to ask questions, do reasoning,
and get responses and get
solutions much faster,
much more quickly, and
with just a simple prompt?
What if we could remove the barriers
between these types of questions
and the insight that's required
to operate your business?
And then what if we take it a step farther
and say, what if you
could act on this data,
and not just the data, but
also have a reasoning partner
with you that can help
you make those decisions?
This is why at Snowflake we created
the Enterprise Intelligence Agent,
and this is what
Snowflake Intelligence is.
It enables everybody from the C-suite
down to the regular business user
and everybody in between
to ask deep questions
of your data, and not just your data,
but every system across your organization,
whether that's Salesforce,
your customer platform,
all of your databases, all
of your data, securely.
And it lets you go a step further.
By using generative AI
and leveraging the power
of these varied models,
it helps you essentially
solve these problems
and ask these questions
that were impossible to answer before.
So what is an Enterprise
Intelligence Agent?
With Snowflake Intelligence,
there's three principles
that really guide and
essentially give you the power
to be able to make decisions in a way
that you weren't able to before.
First, it enables very deep analysis,
so it's not just asking what happened
or getting point-in-time results,
but it helps you reason, it
helps you ask deeper questions
like, what should I do next?
How can I actually improve my sales?
What are the headwinds that
are coming for my business?
And it lets you do deep research
in a way that wasn't possible before.
The second piece here is about trust.
So everybody understands that
with generative AI models,
with a lot of these innovations in gen AI,
it's become increasingly
difficult to really understand
where those answers are coming from,
and actually trust the results
and trust the decisions
that you're making.
With Snowflake Intelligence,
we've enabled you
to have transparent and verified answers,
so questions that get asked oftentimes
can be completely verified
so you know you can trust it.
And also, you have full traceability,
so you're not just receiving, for example,
a dashboard or a graph or a response,
but you can trace that back
all the way to the source
and see every piece of data that informed
that decision at the end.
And then, of course, as you all know,
Snowflake is really known for
their enterprise readiness.
All of this is native to Snowflake,
and it's secured and governed directly
inside of the Snowflake platform,
making sure that you don't have any issues
with data quality, with
security, or governance overall.
What we're trying to do
here is really transform
the way that you use your
enterprise data today.
And enable high-confidence decisions,
decisions you can trust,
and have essentially a reasoning partner
with you at your fingertips
that can help you make those
decisions in real time.
So how do we deliver this?
There's a couple pieces here
inside of Snowflake Intelligence
that are incredibly powerful.
As an example, the ability
to do dynamic discovery.
So again, not just looking at the graph,
but understanding how that graph was made,
having clear explanations
of the requests that you're
making, but also how it reasoned
and came up with a decision for you.
It enables everybody in your organization
to basically test assumptions,
to be able to explore the data,
and to develop comprehensive answers
that your business can
actually operate on.
Second piece here is, again, trust.
Generative AI has its challenges.
Everybody here knows that.
One of the things that we've really sought
and strived to do is basically create
an entire different culture
of how you operate and
use your data today.
What does this mean?
It means that you're able
to not just ask questions
and receive answers in
a black box kind of way,
but it gives you verified answers.
So the questions that get
asked across your business
essentially can be traced
back to every original source.
It'll reformulate the questions for you.
It'll give you explanations,
and everything is transparent,
down to the SQL queries
that are being produced in the background,
and all the reasoning
essentially completely open
for anybody in the organization
to understand how these
decisions are made.
It enables transparency and observability
through and through,
so that you know the answers
that you're receiving
are actually something that's trustworthy
and something that you can
actually run your business on.
And it goes even beyond that.
So, of course, generative AI,
we can ask questions of it.
It can give us answers.
But what we've enabled
here is really the ability
to dive even deeper inside of your data
and actually answer those
very critical questions
that were impossible to answer before.
So with things like Research Mode,
it lets you do deep reasoning
inside of your information
and all of your data across
your entire organization
to really ask those critical questions
that are forward-looking,
as opposed to just receiving reports.
It enables, essentially,
the ability for you
to use all your data,
your multimodal data,
unstructured, in a single place.
And it lets you ask questions
of this complex data
and get comprehensive answers
that basically take into account
everything that your
organization is doing.
In addition to that,
it enables you to
connect to varied sources
from our marketplace
to your enterprise data
and everything in between.
All of this together, so you
can ask comprehensive questions
with actual real insights that
take everything into account,
not just a single database
or a single source,
but everything together to enable
those deep questions and deep answers.
Basically, with Snowflake Intelligence,
we're enabling a new way for your business
to operate and work.
It's all of your knowledge in one place.
It's all of it together.
And it lets you ask questions
that were impossible to answer before.
And all of this, in real time,
at the fingertips of everybody
inside of your organization.
So with that, what I'd like
to do is introduce Brian here,
who is the Senior Vice President
of Engineering at Dessau.
Brian, take it away.
- Thanks.
And I just wanted to introduce
Dessau really quickly.
So we are an e-commerce
analytics platform.
And dovetailing with what
Santiago was just speaking about,
our mission is really
to democratize access
to a brand's e-commerce data
to everybody at that business,
from the marketers, to the
executives, to product managers,
so that they can generate
insights and action that data
without being reliant
on an in-house analyst.
We work with over 100
of the most successful e-commerce brands.
So a lot of the governance
and multi-tenancy
that comes with Snowflake
was really important to us.
So just kind of going through our story.
Before Snowflake Intelligence,
this is kind of what
our stack looked like.
So we effectively bring together
all the data that's really
relevant to an e-commerce brand,
from their commerce platform,
like Shopify or Magento,
their marketing channels,
other plugins that they might be running
in the e-commerce platform.
We also pull in third-party
enrichment data from Axiom
to provide our customers
with a more well-rounded
view of their customers,
including demographic and
psychographic information.
We run all that through our
data pipeline into Snowflake,
where we basically create
a dedicated data warehouse
for each of our clients,
and have an application
experience sitting on top of that.
Now, our applications and the
dashboards that we have there,
the original intent was
really to kind of go beyond
the reporting that they had available
in their native platforms,
in their e-commerce platform,
or in their ESP, stitch
all that data together
to enable richer customer
lifecycle reporting
for their e-commerce brand.
What we notice, as we
pulled all that together,
is that there's a large variance
from how one brand operates
to another brand, right?
You know, we onboard some brand,
and maybe they have a retail business
running on Shopify POS.
They're like, "Hey,
well, let's just kind of
"set that data to the side.
"Let's just focus on our
e-commerce business."
Or they wanna go deep into
kind of product analytics,
but their product analytics may be sitting
in their commerce platform,
some of it may be sitting in an ERP.
And the more flexibility that we built
into our BI dashboards,
the more complex it
became for the executives,
the more non-technical folks
to kind of get access to those insights,
and they became increasingly reliant
on our customer success team
to really operate the software for them.
So our data analysts were kind of busy
developing new features,
kind of suturing up all the discrepancies
on how they might represent their data
on the e-commerce platform.
And it ended up that we basically became
like an outsourced data
team for our clients.
So the challenge for us was
we've now become the barrier,
just like data teams become the barrier
for having their executive stakeholders
get access to that data
in a timely fashion
for them to be able to get the insights
and activate the marketing
tactics that they'd like to.
So in the AI world, we
kind of took a step back
and we thought, how do we
remove ourselves as a barrier?
And once again, enable our customers
to really get in there and get
access to this data quickly.
And we started to think
about whether or not
we could build an AI agent
to basically be like
our e-commerce analyst,
an AI-based e-commerce analyst.
And we started to think about
what that would entail for us.
We have clients asking questions.
Oftentimes there's a fair amount,
and forgive me, probably
all of you in the room
have gone through this,
fair amount of clarification
that you need to dig into
to really understand their intent.
We really wanted to explain
what we were doing for them
when they asked a question and why,
so they could course correct if needed,
or at least they had
confidence in the data.
We wanted to make sure that we
had good monitoring solutions
to understand how our clients
were using the software,
where we can make improvements,
what they were expecting
out of the AI analyst.
Being able to evaluate and test our agent
as we made model updates,
as we maybe made changes
to some of our data representations.
And then ultimately, how
do we take all of this
and move it into a context
they're more familiar with,
providing visualizations and insights
that they could take to
the rest of their business.
We went off earlier this
spring, early summer,
and started prototyping this
against several AI frameworks,
and quickly discovered
that this is gonna be a
significant investment for us,
especially for a startup of our size.
We had to not only get the LLMs in,
but we had to build up the vector stores,
representing the knowledge
of how our brand's data was structured.
Brands not gonna come to us and say,
"Hey, I'm looking for product category X."
They're just gonna say,
"Hey, I really wanna know about jeans."
One client that might
be a product category,
another client that might be
how they label their
products, the product title.
We need to provide that
information to the LLM
to be able to access
the right data points.
We also wanted to push additional analyses
and brand context in, so
that the agent had that,
or the LLM had that information.
So there was an effort, basically,
about providing context.
We also found that the accuracy of the SQL
that was coming out of
a lot of the solutions
we were looking at was subpar.
And when it's returning SQL to
us, we were like, "Oh, crap.
"How are we gonna explain
this to a non-technical person
"when the SQL goes wrong?"
That looked like a challenge to us.
We had kind of evaluated other ways
to retrieve the data and provide it.
But then when we started falling back
to using some of our BI data models,
we were concerned that
we were gonna be limited
by the inflexibility of the BI models
like we had in our previous
reporting solutions.
We really wanted to have
something that provided
that rich, just generative SQL experience
so that we had full
expressivity of the SQL
to be able to run whatever
analysis that a client wanted to.
If they had a really
interesting customer segment
they wanted to look at,
people who purchased X twice
and then came back and purchased
Y a couple months later,
have at it.
You can go do that in SQL. It
was always a challenge for us
to kind of build those
things out into our BI models
in a way that was accessible.
And then at the end of it, it was like,
"Okay, how do we build
the evaluation harness?
"And then how do we get visualizations
"back into the user experience?"
Because at the end of the day,
picture's worth a thousand words.
So I think it was at a Snowflake
Summit last year in June,
we saw the announcement
around intelligence
and we started very
aggressively asking our rep
for access to Snowflake Intelligence
to start playing with it.
We felt like we were ripe
for running this exploration.
We already had Snowflake data warehouses
for each of our clients.
So if we were looking at
an intelligence solution,
we were already gonna be able to draft off
of all the data governance
that we had set up in Snowflake
for this new AI offering.
There wasn't gonna be an
additional lift for us
on that side, or very limited.
We also had a lot of semantic data
that we already had in DBT.
Even when we were building
this out against AI,
we were like, "Okay, where do we get
"the semantic information to
really feed into the models
"to understand how they're
pulling this data?"
So we had this in a DBT and we were like,
"Okay, this looks extremely
promising for us."
So we started to look at
what it was gonna take
for us to set up Snowflake Intelligence.
And really, there's
only a couple of things.
We wanted to set up a semantic view,
or multiple views, per client.
And the semantic view,
think of it as describing
your dimensions, your
facts, your table structure,
the relationships there,
and wrapping all of that
into descriptions, more
natural language descriptions
for the model to read.
We knew that we also
needed search services.
Those are optional, but for us,
we already, from our earlier experiences,
knew that when we wanted to
go into these more free-formed
product discovery type questions,
it was really gonna accelerate and improve
the user experience if
we had those in place.
And then, the agent
configuration, the instructions,
the model, et cetera.
So we started looking at our stack
and figuring out how we were
gonna implement all this.
So we started from our
DBT model documentation.
And so, any of you who
are familiar with DBT,
you've got your models,
your logical table name,
the description, the
columns, descriptions,
and data types at that level.
We were like, okay, this is great.
This is a jumping-off point
for our semantic view.
We're just gonna extend this.
We're gonna use the
MetaField feature within DBT
to add additional semantic information
that we wanted to push into Snowflake.
So we found aliases,
synonyms, sample values,
whether or not we wanted
to index a particular field
with the Cortex search service
to be able to perform fuzzy matching.
And we just extended all this
into our DBT model templates.
Easy enough.
From there, the semantic
views in Snowflake,
they're YAML files.
They look, if any of you
have built semantic views
in other tools or BI tools,
it looks very similar.
So we're like, okay, well, great.
We're just gonna build
little Jinja templates
on top of that to produce the YAML files.
So you'll see we've kind of
pulled together the manifest.
We'll pull it into the context.
And it's like, okay, well,
I'm gonna go reference my orders model.
I'm just gonna pull the
description through,
pull the dimensions through, the facts.
The only things I'm really kind of adding
into this template that
are interesting here
are derived metrics.
I wanna run certain calculations
to have well-defined metrics
that are available
within the semantic view.
I think we had our relationships in here.
And as Santiago was speaking to earlier,
we also introduced verified queries here.
Primarily in our use case,
we were looking for things
that didn't quite fit cleanly
into maybe a derived metric definition,
but something that we
wanted to show the agent,
how do I produce this type of a query?
So for us, just for context,
it's something like retention rates,
where it's like, okay,
there's an initial cohort,
and there's a size of,
how many customers did
I bring in in March?
And then how many of them came
back and purchased in June
or in the next quarter?
So we provide a couple of
verified queries like that
in these semantic views.
And then ultimately,
kind of built this out into
our deployment pipeline.
So when we go to deploy into Snowflake,
and to build an intelligence,
we will run dbt, we'll
run a compile command
to build a manifest file.
We'll pull all that together
with our semantic view templates and YAML,
the agent instructions.
We have this little library
called DecileCortexGen,
which effectively goes off to Snowflake,
and it provisions multiple
layers of the stack,
from the semantic views
used by Cortex analysts
to the search services
to the agents for Snowflake intelligence.
So all that kind of gets
packaged up very neatly for us
just coming off of our
deployment pipeline.
And so here, not too many
developer days after that,
we basically started to have
a stack that looked like this.
We had our manifest file coming through,
we were deploying all
these into Snowflake,
and then through the
Snowflake intelligence UI,
we were able to pull
users in really quickly.
So for us, time to market was imperative,
and what we really liked
was in the Snowflake stack,
we could start with the UI,
we could pull in a couple of
our trusted client accounts,
people that we knew that
were kind of be familiar,
like kind of logging into
Snowflake, accessing intelligence,
and we gave them access,
oh, I don't know, July.
We were like, okay, let's
start playing around with this,
let's start iterating together.
I wanna start observing
what types of questions they're asking,
start to use that to inform
where we're investing,
how we're building out
our models, et cetera.
So they started asking
these really cool questions
that in the past would have been,
some of them would have been
more time-consuming analyses.
My favorite session was
one of our clients came in,
and was like, I launched a new
product earlier last month,
how's it performing?
And I was like, oh man, in
our pre-existing solution,
there's a couple of different
ways I would think about that.
You know, is it bringing in
like kind of a new client demographic?
I would go to one report for that.
You know, how is it reporting
or performing in terms of returns?
Okay, well, there's a
product returns report,
let me go look at that.
Let me go look at, you know,
whether or not these
people are coming back
and making another purchase.
Or what are they co-purchasing?
All those things kind of pulled together.
She just sat down and she
just rapid-fired questions
within 15 minutes, you know,
without having to do any sort of like
kind of deep diving into reports
to like kind of mine the insights herself,
or setting filters to like limit it
to the particular new fabric
that they had launched.
She had these answers.
That was really cool.
It was really cool to see that.
In the past, you know,
it would have been like,
ah, you know, why don't
you guys go do that for me?
So one of the other
pieces that kind of like
led to us adopting Snowflake
was the fact that they,
it's not just a UI, but that
they have API level access
at every level of the stack.
So, you know, the same
things that we were showing
in Snowflake Intelligence earlier,
you get all that through
the Cortex Agents API.
So for us, we were able
to port that experience,
the same experience that our
initial pilot customers had,
into our own application and
produce our own, you know,
branded e-commerce analyst,
AI-powered e-commerce analyst named Luma
as a feature within our application.
All again, this is just
an API integration.
It was sitting on top
of the same resources.
There was no new provisioning
that we needed to do.
So we were able to kind of
migrate those initial customers
from the Snowflake Intelligence
UI into Cortex Agents.
Similarly, there's like APIs
at the Cortex Analyst level.
So if we ever wanted to pop off
and maybe do inferencing in
like a different framework,
we could also take Cortex Analysts
and its text-to-SQL capabilities,
leverage that and, you know,
kind of whatever like other
kind of agentic frameworks
we needed to use.
So for us, this has been a game changer.
We've been able to take, you know,
all this information that
was previously locked
behind dashboards and make
it accessible to our clients
through a natural language chat interface.
I'm just gonna walk through
a little bit of, you know,
what this looks like for our clients.
So again, we've had a
couple of our clients,
Emily at Lake Pajamas and
Becky at Caddis Eyewear.
They were early pilot users for us.
And, you know, this is
kind of what they said,
that they were like,
"Hey, just, we weren't
doing the analysis before.
"It was taking us too much
time to go access the data."
Even when we had like kind of reports,
they were like, "I would
go download two things,
"try to stitch things together
"to really understand what was going on."
And they didn't have to do that anymore.
And their marketing channel owners
are now empowered to come in
and actually make those queries
or ask the questions
that they're looking for
and get the results back.
The other thing that all of our clients
have really highlighted in the feedback
is the thinking steps that
Santiago was showing earlier.
Being able to see what the
agent is doing in the background
and not just at a SQL level.
You can do it at a SQL
level if you know SQL.
But because the semantic view's in place,
it's like, "Hey, I'm
gonna go hit this field
"and I'm filtering for this."
Or, "I'm gonna look at
this property over here."
Seeing it at that level
has given our users
a lot of confidence that
the data that they're seeing
is accurate and complete.
I fundamentally don't think
that we would actually
have a product without
those thinking steps
because it's just too much of a black box.
And that natural kind of
ideation and collaboration
that happens when you're
actually sitting in person
with an analyst.
Like, "Oh, I asked, can I have this?
"Go run a market basket analysis for me
"for the last two years."
"Oh, okay, I'll start last November."
"Oh, actually, we changed
our products in March.
"Let's just go back to March of 2024
"and go run that same analysis."
Since the thinking steps kind of shows you
what it's doing along
every step of the way,
clients come in and they
can kind of course correct
throughout the session.
And that's been great.
So for us, on the decile side,
what Snowflake Intelligence has given us
is really a turnkey AI framework
to quickly launch to our customers.
We're able to provide quicker access.
We were able to get our
product and our agents
in the market faster and
start building confidence
that we had something that was viable,
even before we ran through the integration
into our own application.
But because it has the
flexibility of not just the UI,
but all the API endpoints underneath,
we had flexibility going forward
in terms of how we might want to iterate
and evolve our agentic solution.
But already, it's reduced the stream
of custom analytics
reports that we're doing.
It's helped our users transition
from mining data in a report
to actually extracting the insights.
For the clients who are
already on our AI solution,
we see about a 75% reduction
in their support asks.
So they're able to come in,
one value pop of ours
is running segmentation.
They're able to come in and just express
what segments they do
without having to understand
group by logic, for instance.
They're just able to say,
"Hey, I wanna go find people
"who purchased the same
product three plus times
"over the last six months
because I want them
"to join my subscription program."
They're able to come
in, just type that out,
and get to a customer segment
that they can then activate
through our platform and
go push up to their ESP,
and immediately run a
campaign against them.
So for us, this has been a game changer,
and we've been really excited
to partner with Snowflake
on getting this product to market.
Roadmap on our side, like I mentioned,
this first step for us has been,
after we got Snowflake
Intelligence set up,
integrating with the Agents API,
really pulling all that experience
into our own application.
And again, that's
one-to-one with what you see
within the intelligence world.
Optimizing workflows
within our application,
making the data portable.
So if you saw some of the
results in the previous slides,
we can take a table of customer IDs,
effectively just click a button,
migrate it to a segment
within our platform,
and then click another button,
and then go sync it up to Klaviyo
for some sort of an email campaign.
Next things for us,
and I think this is kind
of a critical point for us
in terms of making this
product successful,
is being able to
customize the instructions
on a per-brand level.
Again, we're working with 150-ish clients.
It's hard for us to manage all the nuances
of every brand, right?
One brand runs a gift program
on a certain platform.
Others run subscriptions.
There's three or four
different primary vendors
on the Shopify world.
Wholesale, retail, how
they wanna handle that.
What they mean by customer value.
All that information is context
that we kind of know about the brands,
but being able to encode that
and push that up to the agent.
And then I think aspirationally,
being able to work with the
hands-on keyboard more employees
to be able to infuse those
types of instructions
and the context about who the brand is
into the agent themselves
to help inform the agent
what types of analyses
it should be running
for different types of verticals within
the e-commerce space.
And the last thing on our piece
is actually trying to build
scheduling and alerting.
Again, when we're trying to
build an agentic e-commerce
analyst, an analyst should be able
to run background tasks for you, right?
Wake up Monday morning,
go run anomaly detection,
go tell me if I have an inventory item
that I need to go restock.
Tell me if sales of a particular
product fell off last week.
These are things that people are doing
with our platform today that ultimately,
now that we have agents in place,
being able to enable our
clients to schedule out
on a recurring basis to be able to say,
go pop that up on Monday
and go give me this report,
just like they would if they
had a human analyst in-house.
So these are some of the exciting features
that we're looking to build
into Luma here shortly.
If you wanna learn more
about Luma AI by Decile,
you can go access that QR code there.
It'll take you to our product page.
- Okay, that's all I have for you,
but we did have a demo plan,
unfortunately it didn't work out.
But if you come by the Snowflake booth,
we'd be happy to show you
Snowflake Intelligence
in real time.
And Brian and I will be
here and be available
if you all wanna chat anymore.
Thank you all so much.
- All right, thank you.
(audience applauds)